on va compter les points on va voir
d'accord est ce que christian clavier
votre ami je peux pas dire ça je ne le
connais pas assez
oui il ya hockey ou pas écoute je ne
connais pas assez leur nom à mais
j'aimerais bien à ça vous le choc
l'expression se débarrasser de la
racaille au karcher
non parce que c'est le langage qui est
employé dans les cités elle même un par
les gens des cités en fait c'est la
question que vous voulez demander tirer
se demander s'ils avaient le pen à cet
anniversaire et ben nous la réponse est
non c'est à choquer toit se débarrasser
de la racaille au karcher
je crois que nicolas est prêt pour faire
la prochaine campagne pour éléphant bleu
ça vous a choqué le retour des
couvre-feux oui ces billes pas qu'il a
des idées non j'aime pas ça j'aime pas
ça et je suis pas sûr même que cette loi
s'il avait été soumis au conseil
constitutionnel et de 1955 1 1
je suis pas sûr que l aurait franchi le
barrage du conseil constitutionnel
d'ailleurs nicolas elle n'a pas employé
pratiquement pas de manière
infinitésimale
sérieusement vous pensez pas qu'on était
trop patient avec tous ces gens là en
banlieue non non on n'a pas été trop
patient ne pensez pas qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france
non j'en suis un moi-même pensais pas
qu'on était bien gentil quand même
jusqu'à maintenant
non je pense qu'à ça c'est difficile
l'intégration et il faut prendre du
temps et il faut de la patience
vous pensez pas que les chômeurs sont
tous des fainéants non je pense que le
chauffage est une fatalité vie mais bien
jean pierre pernaut
je ne connais pas je connais vous voyez
oui mais peu son journal c'est pas mon
c'est pas mes oreilles les reportages
sur les sabots c'est bien qu'on n'avait
pas vu le vrai bel ouvrage
les artisans en france lisf le supprimer
ou pas isf c'est ce qui détruit une
partie du capitalisme français le
résultat c'est que nos entreprises se
sont attrapés par le capitalisme
international c'est vous irez de
privatiser la sécurité sociale je pense
que c'est pas à l'ordre du jour n'a pas
beaucoup de sens vous avez acheté des
actions d'edf
non le kärcher
ça monte carlo c'est vrai est-ce que
vous pensez que nicolas sarkozy est
plutôt belle sommes quand même il faut
demander aux femmes ce n'est pas ce qui
m'a attiré chez lui en tous les cas vous
en pensez quoi
c'est pas le sujet en train ça peut
aider en politique un général boulanger
l'été bel homme
oui mais c'est mal quand l'arrêté pas
mal non plus vraiment génial vraiment
bas villepin est assez bel homme oui pas
et il parait t'il dit pas paraît-il
enfin vous voyez bien quand même à lille
anne saint nicolas non mais je vous dis
simplement c'est aux femmes de porter un
jugement le jugement des hommes sur les
autres hommes est généralement faux vous
trouvez que ça fait [ __ ] non pas du tout
je si j'ai adoré son grade et au
bien-être anglais
vous voyez voiliers class exactement
comme ils corps du karcher c'est avec
une réponse à une question que l'on vous
condamnent vous avez combien d'albums de
michel sardou chez vous j'en ai pas je
suis pas si vous êtes de droite
finalement c'est plutôt léo ferré et moi
ouais à holla holla holla pas je
servirai de l'ump un archer vous aimez
les hommes et que des mocassins à glands
il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir des
mocassins pour être un gland lui jack ou
check in black
non vous pleuré en entendant la
marseillaise non est ce que vous pouvez
trouver cinq éléments positifs dans le
bilan de jacques chirac
oui bien sûr oui par exemple je trouve
très bien la déclaration de jacques
chirac sur l' esclavage croyant je
trouve très bien
la déclaration que jacques chirac avait
fait sur la rafle du vel d'hiv très bien
en 95 formida très bien on est 2 révèle
2 2 je trouve très bien la position
qu'il a pris sur maastricht
oui mais il a permis que ça passe alors
que s'il avait fait la politique du pire
plus c'est vrai on aurait échoué
bon on peut rajouter l'irak il a refusé
de faire la guerre avec les américains
car ils n'étaient pas là il est en
vacances à l'heure les fonds consacrés à
quoi vous faisiez vous êtes d'accord
je suis d'accord avec ces biens se fait
quatre n'ont plus qu'une villa il a été
favorable aux eaux des nationalisations
dès 1986 et il a eu raison parce que
c'était le sens de l'économie mondiale
vous trouvez normal vous qu'on vendra
quelqu'un qui appartient à tout le monde
qu'est ce qui appartient à tous pas
quand on a privatisé tf1 oui a vendu à
monsieur bouygues mais ya eu de l'argent
est reparti il est où l'argent mais il
est dans les caisses de l'état
ça a été souvent et l'état il a fichu en
l'air mais c'est quand même pas de la
faute
je sais les français qui avaient payé
tf1 c'est les français mais il y avait
un jour en est un qui sait le libérant
les gens du au bon prix 1
on dit toujours ça quand on a vendu
quand on a vendu on dit toujours que
c'est on a dû passer chez réalités
propres des vendeurs de trouver qui
n'ont pas vendu assez cher vous avez
déjà rêvé érotiquement de villepin et
l'aidera s'en souviennent est ce que
vous trouvez qu'ils aient assez de flics
en france
oui il y en a assez comment il vivait à
3 contre 17
vous trouvez que la france va mieux
depuis 2002 elle va mieux qu'avant 2002
ah ouais en quoi par exemple à notre
économie c'est davantage dynamiser que
ne l'était à ce moment là non
sérieusement je peux aussi vous faire
allant du tour pour vous l'expliquer
mais je le pense
il ya un déficit colossal on est dans
l'intérêt de la france et vingt mille
euros par personne ou le déficit le
déficit en lorraine depuis 1981 sam a
raison ça s'est accumulé ça c'est pas
moi c'est l'autre alors qu'avant c'était
un petit d'accord mais bon vous avez été
là oui on a pas on n'a pas redressé la
france en quatre ans ça c'est sûr
comment il faut de temps pour redresser
la france
franchement il faut surtout peut-être
beaucoup d'énergie ouais c'est la raison
pour laquelle soutient nicolas sarkozy a
parce qu'il en a beaucoup
garder paul un haut rhin jean gagne
voilà qu'à écouter oui mais on réfléchit
nous on va aller voter on est troisièmes
gynéco ministère de la culture
pourquoi pas mais j'ai passé on a
vraiment envie s'il n'y a pas au bureau
le matin ça dure trop sage pour ça
est-ce que vous pensez que seuls les
plus forts sont sortiront et c'est très
bien comme ça
d'abord je pense que les plus forts ne
s'en sortiront pas nécessairement tout
seul et c'est pas très bien comme ça je
ne crois pas la loi du plus fort
pensez pas qu'il faudrait interdire le
cannabis mais il est interdit
oui c'est vrai que la région
c'est un service c'est marrant parce
qu'on s'adapte à chaque fois faudrait
pourrait l'interdire encore plus non
parce que je crois au contraire ça c'est
correctionnalisé aujourd'hui moi je suis
plutôt partisan d'en faire une amende et
le taux du crédit on peut le bc pour les
gens qui n'ont que très peu d'argent
pour acheter du cannabis toujours il ya
d'ailleurs en ce moment un projet
deux banques spéciale pour
les gens en difficulté qui est une qui
est une qui est une banque d'un
caractère social très particulier et qui
sera subventionné par l'état mais j'ai
bien hâte enthousiaste est ce que vous
êtes contre le mariage des homosexuels
non ça ne me scandalise pas vous êtes
contre l'adoption d'enfants par les
couples gays ou lesbiens rennes me
scandalise pas ah ouais ça nous pourrons
contre je suis pour la liberté donc et
je vais vous dire une chose dont on n'a
pas assez pris conscience c'est déjà
possible parce que premièrement
l'adoption par un célibataire est
permise par la loi c'est une loi de 1994
donc faites par la droite et
deuxièmement le conseil d'état jugé
depuis longtemps que refuser l'adoption
d'un enfant sous le prétexte que
l'adoptant est homosexuel et illégale
donc l'adoption des enfants par les
homosexuels c'est déjà bien enfin il est
fort nous fait toujours avocats non mais
je vous prendrai bien pour les auchan
est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
peine de mort dans certains cas n'a
alors j'allais très précis je suis
abolitionniste l'elysée un enfant je
suis abolitionniste de plus j'ai
toujours été abolitionniste libéral de
la musique sur internet
est ce que vous êtes heureux qu'on
retrouve bientôt le pauvre alain juppé
bien sûr je pense que comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs suggéré tout à l'heure que la
peine qu'il a subis pas nécessairement
équitable un écart tous les cas ce sera
bien pour lui quand ça se termine
j'aurais pas que le smic ça pénalise un
peu la reprise économique quand même le
smic c'est surtout indispensable pour
vivre
pensez pas que les français sont une
population d'assistés quand même mieux
je pense que le système le modèle social
est mauvais voilà et qu' il n'ya pas
d'incitation à l'effort mais assister
les gens quand ils sont en difficulté
pour qu'ils surmontent leurs difficultés
et pour les encourager à faire des
efforts du pot ça vous énerve les jeunes
qui portent des tee shirts guevara n'ont
donc pas du tout non je fais
suffisamment connue étant jeune pour une
pâleur projet ausone maintenant 8 à 25
ans vous êtes de gauche d'extrême gauche
molle